thanks for joining us America I'm Dave
Ramsey your host Steve is with us in
South Bend Indiana and his 18 year old
daughter is dating a 22 year old young
man they're getting very serious or both
in church they're good good young people
he thinks the guy's a great guy his
family are all Dave Ramsey people
meaning they're handling their money
smart and with common sense his daughter
is too and he wonders when he can begin
to broach the subject with the young man
and he may have said a couple of times
and as he thinks they're going a little
too fast towards the altar is that a
fair summary of what you told me Steve
exactly okay I don't first thing I want
you to do is I'm going to put you on
hold when we're done and Kelly's going
to pick up I'm going to send you a copy
of my favorite book on the subject of
fathers and daughters it's called strong
father's strong daughters by dr. Meg
Meeker thank you dr. Meeker is a good
friend of mine meg is and she's been on
the show here several times there's a
huge correlation between a lady's
successful life and her relationship
with her dad and the book is very
encouraging for you to be very plugged
into the situation our society says that
has discounted the value of men and men
in the home and the book really
encourages you to say hey I need to man
up and be in my daughter's life
especially in this kind of a situation
absolutely if you have a unique place
here now that that is not that's not
control freaking but it's establishing
influence and using it and so I would
start the conversation first with your
daughter and circle back to her and
really by circle back I mean these are
conversations you've had with her before
and say you know I'm really excited
about so-and-so and he's a good young
man I want to remind you that you
believe and our family believes certain
things about money and the reason we
believe those things is their biblical
and they're smart and I think it's good
for you and whatever his name is to
begin to talk about some of those
subjects and I'm going to begin to talk
to him about it talk to him about them
as your dad and as his friend
and that's not to say you sit him down
and go okay how many credit cards you
got bub that's not what we're talking
about we're just saying hey you know one
of the things I learned when I was your
age I did some dumb things with money
and I learned that you know getting into
debt didn't work and I learned that if I
lived on a budget and one of the guys I
read and study says that the number one
cause of divorce in North America number
one problem in male-female relationships
is money and money problems and so as I
see your relationship maturing with my
daughter I just want to say that out
loud to you and I want you to know I'm
here as your friend to mentor you or to
lead you in some of those discussions
and I'll help you any way I can and I'm
going to show you some things and as you
guys get more and more serious
those things I'm talking to you about
are probably going to become a
requirement for you to continue to get
more serious hmm because in order to
qualify for my daughter's hand you're
going to have to have what's known as a
freaking clue right she's a princess and
I'm going to expect her to be treated
that way by you the rest of her life hmm
and you know I'm you can get you can
have some fun with that mixing humor
it's not you hammering the guy that's
not the point but I've had all of those
talks informally informally before they
ever sat down with their hands wet and
sweat on their upper lip asking for my
blessing
to asked her in hand in marriage now I
will tell you that the statistics tell
us that at least a six-month engagement
and you know a 14-year engagement is not
necessary but somewhere around a
six-month engagement or range is a lot
of statistical evidence that that leads
towards a good marriage people who are
date three days and get married don't
usually have as good a shot at staying
married right and so but but it's not
required that this happens two years I
mean a six-month engagement and that
means they're dating for a long time
before they of some kind but before they
decide to get married but at least that
deep in detail in depth pre-marriage
counseling to discover what's wrong with
her family and what's wrong with his
family and they talk about it ahead of
time because everybody comes into the
marriage busted by their own families
right and you got to know that stuff
going in
and uh and you know I suggested strongly
Financial Peace University for my
daughters and their another requirement
and they're young men as a as a part of
the blessing I didn't say it was
contingent but I said you know a wise
young man in your shoes would do these
three things at least you would at least
get into detailed in-depth pre-marriage
counseling you would be engaged at least
six months and you would go through
Financial Peace University those if you
do those three things you really are way
on your way statistically towards
success and what you don't want to enter
a marriage it's too it's too complicated
and too too crummy if you do it wrong so
you don't want to enter it without all
the deck stacked in your favor and so
that's kind of how I had it it's just
like a older brother wisdom discussion
with this young man but he and he takes
the implication he takes what I'm
implying to be those are requirements
but if you do it right and you know and
you're not you know you're not beating
him down with it you're just saying hey
this is just a smart way to live
and you might do it for the kid next
door if he's thinking about getting
married you know right it's the same
kind of cut tone is what I'm saying and
then I will tell you this from
experience i i'm a girl i cried movies
and so i figured i was going to cry all
the way down the aisle taking my
daughters down the aisle i didn't shed a
single tear and people like i can't
believe it because you cried everything
you create baby and I took me a while to
realize I was excited because they both
scored great young men great young men
and it made it very easy to give them
away yeah that's what I want to get it
too and that's why that's why this time
for me is so important that I want to
make a hundred percent sure that this is
going to work this is the right one and
so I just felt like that I was getting
pushed a little bit that they want maybe
Tennessee they're waiting on dad here
allowed it to go forward and I'm like
well you guys are dating you guys are
fine how long have they been dating
about six months okay well they're
they're getting pretty close then
probably so you know what I would do is
just say hey here's some things to look
at and I'm not going to control-freak
you and I man I got to tell you both I
really appreciate the
respect and honor you're giving me by
giving me the ability to tap the brakes
and here's the only reasons I would tap
the brakes is on these two or three
things here and you know I just gave you
my three but there's there's others you
might have something else you're
concerned about that I don't know about
but I'm right you know I mean there may
be let's say for instance there's
something going on in his family that's
a little crazy that you're aware of and
you would just say well how's that going
to affect you guys you got to know that
that's when you marry you marry the
whole family and so and every family's
got some crazy in it somewhere
absolutely it's just a matter of
discovering where sooner than later and
setting reasonable boundaries around it
every family some of it some of it's a
little more behind the curtain and some
of it's just crazy in the street but but
it's there and so you know you just kind
of talk that stuff through with them and
hey you know you've been praying if
you're like me you've been praying for
this her mate since she was little and
you know be open to the idea that God
probably sent her an imperfect guy kind
of like he sent your wife and that's
kind of how I had to look at it but my
sons in law I mean huh they're like sons
to me there I've just I scored but I
used to say I hit the son-in-law lottery
but I didn't I really I taught my girls
to pick well this is what a man looks
like it's what manhood looks like and
you'll recognize it when you see it
darling and then they found it you know
a couple of them dated lowboys a couple
times but they pretty good they get they
didn't have a lot of tolerance for
little boys they they pretty much wanted
men and and you know that's not that's
not a chronological thing by the way
that's an emotional and spiritual
maturity I'm talking about
you